hey guys welcome back to planet coaster
today's episode marks the start of a
little 3 episode run in which our
attempts to finish the main street
reason being is that I don't think I can
continue much longer on this park and
I've sort of been giving signs about
this a little bit as well but I just
want to quickly explain it here
basically I just want to start wrapping
it up and release a video of it sometime
soon and also release it in the park
file because I don't think I can work on
the park much longer given the fact that
alpha 2 is coming pretty soon and I do
wanna start a new park in alpha 2 not to
mention that this park is gonna feel
somewhat outdated with the new stuff
that comes out in alpha 2 and instead of
dwelling on the past I just want a
really experiment with some of the new
things in the new alpha and just leave
this as the sort of alpha 1 Park my plan
has always been to just make one Park
borough alpha state of the game so you
can also kind of see the progression
happening there so I will release this
park in both day video and the park file
before the new Alpha comes out but
there's not a lot of time left and I'm
sort of going to be quite busy this
period of time so I'll try to get this
done as quickly as I can and sort of I'm
in the sort of wrapping up of the park
stage at this point and the most
important things were that I just really
wanted to finish those parts of the park
which would make like the the
immersiveness like would really break
the immersion if they weren't finished
so the Main Street for instance was a
really important part there also still
some like small unfinished parts in the
Japanese area I also may address some
parts of the Roman area but it's mostly
things like that which I'll go over
until I release the park and the park
will be released partly unfinished in a
sense that I won't start a new area and
the rest of the park will just be filled
with some trees and some places will
just be kept open and I might probably
just put some coming soon billboards
here in there just so maybe people can
pick up the park and have their own
ideas on how they want to finish the
rest of it that would be pretty
interesting really but yeah I basically
won't really finish the entire park at
least not in the sense that I was hoping
to another reason is
actually that's I have been getting into
performance issues lately as I've also
talked about before and even though I'm
really glad I got it to work again
because this is the first episode I
recorded again after numerous times of
trying to get the game to work and it
liked so much I couldn't even work in it
with enormous amounts of UI and mouse
lag but it's alright again so I just
wanted to record some episodes of me
getting stuff done that's most important
to get done but I really don't think I
can push the park much further so I kind
of want to finish it to a presentable
stage while it's still safe to do so
it also means these episodes world gets
maybe a little less experimental because
the park at this point is really just as
not so coherent like collection of
different little experiments and try
outs with different things that I wanted
to make and it's sort of time to try and
connect those different parts of the
park which at the moment don't really
seem so connected and kind of fill in
the gaps that were still left there and
the first thing I wanted to do is give
the Main Street something more
interesting than just a simple building
so I wanted to have a quick simple
restaurants kind of like Casey's corner
except this one is really on a sort of
central plaza in the main streets which
most of the Main Street is also really
built around I would say the Main Street
is going to be quite small in this Plaza
is going to be really the only thing
that the Main Street really has going
for it and I just wanted to have a small
restaurant over here emphasis on small
though I wanted to get a really open
tense feeling and atmosphere to the Main
Street in general so there will be the
more high tall townhouse kind of
buildings and it will be quite closely
packed together so I didn't want to make
this restaurant too large and kind of
seen the make the plaza seem like a
really vast field of just paths and
restaurants hence why it's more built as
a sort of really small alcove kind of
building with just a couple of tables in
front of it to create a general
atmosphere but while still regaining
that sort of really urban feel of the
Main Street in the future which probably
doesn't make any sense at this point in
time
but hopefully it'll make sense at some
point in the future at least that was
the idea when I was building this there
wasn't really any main inspiration for
this building but I just wanted to
create a domed restaurant actually which
is pretty interesting and try a really
standard entrance with a pediment and
just some pillars in front of it to make
it look a bit fancier than just a simple
entrance and I think the most
recognizable thing about this building
is definitely the windows interestingly
I just wanted to try and get like one of
some of these really large arched
windows in and I really felt it would be
quite feasible actually to make these
things by just layering multiple windows
on top of each other and having this
large wall arch around it with just a
couple extra details and that's how they
came out and they are generally the most
unique thing about this building and
something which I do like and actually
worked really well so unless something
new is coming in the future this is
definitely something that I do want to
try a bit more in the future as well but
yeah aside from that it is a pretty
simple building that's said there will
be a dome in the middle of the building
but I'll get to that in the future of
the episode first I wanted to get into
the townhouses and the surroundings of
the building a little bit more to get a
general sense and idea of how the dome
should look to make the restaurant I
kind of work in the rest of the
environment and the rest of the building
is really pretty simple there was lot of
like experimenting with the smaller
pieces to see different ways to make
pillars and cornices and things like
that but it's nothing really unique at
this point in time it's just that with
every single building and this is
something that I try to do in the entire
main street and it's definitely
something that I'll come back a lot when
I work on the town houses buildings are
going to be somewhat similar to regain
or to obtain some sort of general sense
of style within the street and keep it
more as an ensemble and make everything
fit together a little bit but there will
be like smaller differences between the
buildings when it comes to cornices or
balconies or the way the windows are
made or these specific ways that the
pillars are made just to get these very
subtle differences to make these
seemingly very similar buildings still
have some sense of uniqueness to them
while still making it seem like they all
belong together at the same time so yeah
that'll be most of the like
experimenting with things it'll be
mostly about getting new and different
types of cornices dormers doris is
actually something that I'll get to
quite a lot and pillars as well is
something that so now you can actually
make a pretty good variety of pillars
with the things that we have in the game
though I should probably say pilasters
because they're attached to balls but
yeah that is just about it for this
somewhat simple restaurant building it's
it's building that I feel it was really
simple in the way that it's generally
built but it actually still took a lot
of time to build and like one and a half
hours for the like amount of detail that
there is and the way that all of the
details are made so moving on to the
second building this building pretty
much became more or less the blueprints
for the rest of the townhouses in the
area and it's also the reason why I
wanted to make this building before I
actually finished B restaurants and put
the dome on top of that just to get a
general sense of scale of how the main
streets in general is gonna work and how
it's gonna look in the end and yeah this
was basically my first tried it though I
have to say I didn't really have any
specific plan I just kind of got Google
Images I googled French town house and
just kind of went with what the results
gave me in general so that was just
about my very professional approach
there yeah that's pretty much it
what's interesting about this though is
that I really wanted to move away as you
can see with the placement of the door
here from the full tile placement of all
the windows and doors because the
townhouses have like quite closely
packed windows and they're much more
like vertical in appearance because
they're pretty tall and they have these
a lot of vertical elements like pillars
and things like that
and it just works a little bit better I
feel with more dense amount of windows
and also many of the townhouses have
like three or five windows and just
having two windows one on each tile just
felt like it wouldn't be dense enough
and like it wouldn't really work well
for the concept so all of the buildings
are going to be right about two tiles
wide and going to have three windows and
that's the general blueprint and then I
just wanted to have unique cornices and
unique pillars and all that good stuff
for all the different buildings so yeah
I use the same method for many of the
other buildings as well just make a
separate building where you can just
kind of mess with the pillars and get
all of the little details of the pillars
right and then just copy them over into
the building it definitely isn't perfect
like some of the windows and pillars are
definitely offset like some pillars
stick out a little bit more from the
building than others or the distance
between the windows isn't entirely
correct and the building ends up not
being entirely symmetrical as a result
but it's just something that I find is
really hard to do anything against and
as long as it seemed like it was just
about rights I figured it would be good
enough to go it so yeah for the windows
as well over here I wanted to make like
really or some of these really tall
townhouse windows so also interestingly
I wanted the second yeah that is the
second floor the second floor window is
to be smaller than the first floor
window it's not just because they quite
often are in real life but also because
this is actually a fits that many main
streets and very famously the new Disney
main streets too as well like the the
floors on Disney main streets are
actually gradually getting smaller the
higher up they are so the yeah the base
floor is has a pretty high ceiling but
then every floor after that is getting
lower and lower which kind of makes the
building seem a little larger than they
actually are and hence also why I kind
of want to make every single floor on
these townhouses a little smaller than
the floor underneath as well though the
exception with this one being this first
building where the first floor actually
has real
tall windows but yeah that's the general
idea behind it there was also a lot of
playing with different types of roofs
the roofs are pretty steep for these
kinds of townhouses and they are also
quite important to the general look of
the building I find out with Talon
houses like this or with buildings that
have spires or really high towers like
what's on top of the building is really
important for how the building in
general looks and kind of the general
appearance of the building so I really
wanted to make sure that all of these
dormers on the buildings were actually
something that I was happy with and they
felt like some of the most important
elements of these buildings really and
also why I wanted to have these dormers
on top of the buildings which are
composed of different windows and
different small pieces to get just about
the exact thing that I wanted for every
single building yeah the rest of the
building pretty much has a very similar
approach for the rest of the buildings I
should say number anning these
townhouses you can also kind of see how
much of an effect it has on the way that
the restaurant looks because right now I
feel the restaurant is kind of dwarfed
by these townhouses around it I also did
want to have the townhouses get a little
bit larger as as in a little bit taller
as they come closer to the plaza like
the plaza sort of the main area of the
of the entire main streets and kind of
what you're drawn into so I wanted to
have really the largest townhouses right
around here and at this point they do
kind of dwarf the restaurant which is
kind of the little more study that I
wanted to get going here because I was
really afraid that Nene restaurant would
look end up looking a little bit too
small like the idea also behind placing
the restaurant a little bit behind these
townhouses is while keeping that sort of
urban feeling while still having your
restaurant was also to kind of make the
restaurant seem a little larger than it
or a little further away and larger than
it really is because it's not even a
very large building and it's not much
it's not very far behind these
townhouses either but I was really
hoping to get so a general effect where
because the restaurant is placed like a
little further away from the center of
the plaza
and a little lower at the same time as
well it would feel like it's a little
further away and make it seem a little
larger at the same time and it's
something which I think it would work
quite well but doesn't really work well
at this point in time so I figured I
would need quite a large dome on top of
the restaurants to kind of work against
the like the pretty large townhouses and
their heights that they have at the
moment so yeah that's what I wanted to
do with that and now this is actually
interestingly the only building where I
had 2 dormers but the government's don't
actually follow the rest of the layouts
of the building usually like every
single thing on the building follows the
same general layout so for instance the
the the little blocks on the balustrade
on top of the building are exactly in
the same line as the pillars of the
building which are at the same time
exactly in the same sort of vertical
line as the base of the walls of the
building and the same goes for the
windows usually I have the windows in
the exact same vertical line as the
Dorman's on top of the roof but this
building was actually one sort of
exception where I wanted to have 2
dormers just to see how it would kind of
work even though there are three windows
on every single floor I do kind of like
the effects but in general I'm just
slightly more of a fan of the more clean
looking having everything that
everything in the same vertical line
sort of approach to things now with that
out of the way and I just wanted to come
back to the restaurants again to do with
the townhouses having a little bit of a
better idea what the area around the
restaurants is going to look like and at
the tables and a bit of scenery around
the restaurants who make it look a
little bit more inviting I have got I
have gotten quite some comments about
the fact that the general park but
especially the Main Street doesn't look
very theme park ish there's the don't by
the way which is just very easily copied
over from another dome which I'll get to
later but I did get some comments about
the fact that the park isn't looking so
theme park ish because there aren't
really any signs or not too many signs
no no real theme park elements which is
still something that I'll add in the
main street as well some of it will be
added
screen but it also come back in some
future episodes as well but as you can
see here I'm also getting into some more
signs like for instance the like the ice
sort of you know what is that actually I
have no idea but like that neon thing
they're over there to kind of create a
bit more of an atmosphere and I'll get
into other type of restaurant signs and
things like that in the future as well
and when it comes to the dome it is just
a copy of the other dome out of pure
laziness and because it saves time and
it's a lot easier and it just felt like
the perfect dome in the way it looks and
also the size I just kind of placed it
and quickly took a look to see how well
it would actually work and if it kind of
offsets the heights of the town houses
around it pretty well and actually works
perfectly though just to make it a
little bit different and not the exact
same dome I did remove some of the
details and add a couple other things
and I did want to change the top a
little I wasn't too happy about the top
of the other dome there so I wanted to
try this more sort of cupola type thing
on top of the dome to have that little
dome on top of a dome kind of idea and
I'm actually really happy with how that
turned out and in general it is a bit
more of a fancy clean looking down than
the other one so you know that was the
general idea behind that building and
this is just about what I'll actually
get into this episode the rest of this
episode where I should be lighting or
something that I haven't really shown
off too much yet in the rest of the
series and also something which I didn't
get to quite a lot in the main street so
far so just something that I really
wanted to get to still though it's not
as interesting in terms of any decisions
that I had to make I just wanted to make
sure that everything was sort of more or
less well lit there are still some likes
lights are adjustments that I'll make in
the future because it is quite hard to
get this right sometimes many of the
lights like the lanterns are like have a
really small radius they don't really
spread out as much so they can be used
to create a general atmosphere but you
can't really use them to light anything
up and I find the only really good
things to light things up with the
spotlights but at some points there
wasn't really any
nearby where I could place a spotlight
without placing it in the middle of a
path so sometimes I was more or less
forced to use these little attach to
wall kind of lights but the sort of
drawback I find to the wall attached
lights is that they are really bright
and they really light up one particular
small part of the building a lot while
leaving the rest still somewhat dark one
general kind of thing I wanted to keep
in mind here though with the lighting is
that I wanted to have a more atmospheric
sort of feeling to all of the buildings
on the first floor so as you probably
saw all of the lights on the base floor
are just yellow lights and it's sort of
the lantern very orange lights and from
that point onward like the first and the
second floor and the third floor or have
these really white spotlights on them so
there is that contrast between having
the yellow base floor lit lights and the
the rest of the buildings where the
higher floors are all it is very white
light so yeah that was the general idea
there and for the rest I just wanted to
find a way to get this building to
actually light up because obviously this
is the biggest weenie in the park this
is actually the tallest building in the
entire park and I just wanted to make
sure that this building was quite lit
but I also didn't want it to be entirely
white like white really felt like a
color I didn't really want to have here
I wanted to have the tower be a little
bit more atmospheric than just at and
white it's just kind of harsh and not as
natural so I wanted to get this sort of
orangey yellow lights which lights up
the tower but at the same time is still
atmospheric and not too bright so I was
just kind of hard to get the exact right
spots because it's I just had to find
certain areas and certain buildings next
to this building certain places where I
could attach spotlights that would
actually work which is a bit of a hassle
at the moment in the future at least the
knee rotation of objects is going to
help out a lot and make things like this
a lot easier but at the moment you can't
really freely rotate what these
spotlights are going to be rotated
towards so it can be a bit of a
puzzle every now and then to get these
spotlights to be exactly where you want
them to be also I have to say I am like
no lighting master I know that to think
but yeah I am not that kind of person so
I just was kind of looking for a way to
get my buildings to look up to light up
in a nice way over here but in no way am
I like a real expert on this type of
thing unless you count my rct3
experience but that was a completely
different thing and not even that much
anyway and actually yeah over here at
the same sort of approach like the yeah
but the base floor is yellow over there
as well with the top floors being more
white but anyway yeah that's it for this
episode I am just about running out of
time lapse so thank you guys for
watching this episode in the next
episode I'll do some more work on the
Main Street mainly working on some new
townhouses and in the episode after that
which is just very newly recorded I'll
finish the main streets and maybe get to
something else so hope to see you then